what's your computer setup what uh
what's like the perfect are you somebody
that's flexible to no matter what laptop
four screens yeah uh or do you uh prefer
a certain setup that you're most
productive um I guess the one that I'm
familiar with is one large screen uh 27
inch
um and my laptop on the side water
operating system I do Max that's my
primary for all tasks I would say OS X
but when you're working on deep learning
everything is Linux your SSH into a
cluster and you're working remotely but
what about the actual development like
that using the IDE so you would use uh I
think a good way is you just run vs code
um my favorite editor right now on your
Mac but you are actually you have a
remote folder through SSH
um so the actual files that you're
manipulating are on the cluster
somewhere else so what's the best IDE
a code what else did people so I use
emacs still that's cool uh so it may be
cool I don't know if it's maximum
productivity
um so what what do you recommend in
terms of editors you worked with a lot
of software Engineers editors for
python C plus plus machine learning
applications I think the current answer
is vs code currently I believe that's
the best
um IDE it's got a huge amount of
extensions it has a GitHub copilot
um uh integration which I think is very
valuable what do you think about the the
co-pilot integration I was actually uh I
got to talk a bunch with Guido and
Rossum who's the creator of python and
he loves Coppola he like he programs a
lot with it yep uh do you
yeah he's copilot I love it and uh it's
free for me but I will pay for it yeah I
think it's very good and the utility
that I found with it was is in is it I
would say there is a learning curve and
you need to figure out when it's helpful
and when to pay attention to its outputs
and when it's not going to be helpful
where you should not pay attention to it
because if you're just reading its
suggestions all the time it's not a good
way of interacting with it but I think I
was able to sort of like mold myself to
it I find it's very helpful number one
in uh copy paste and replace some parts
so I don't um when the pattern is clear
it's really good at completing the
pattern and number two sometimes it
suggests apis that I'm not aware of so
it tells you about something that you
didn't know so and that's an opportunity
to discover and you it's an opportunity
to see I would never take copilot code
AS given I almost always uh copy a copy
this into a Google Search and you see
what this function is doing and then
you're like oh it's actually actually
exactly what I need thank you copilot so
you learned something so it's been part
of search engine apart maybe getting the
exact syntax correctly that once you see
it yep it's that NP hard thing to say
once you see it you know yes exactly
correct exactly you yourself you can
struggle you can verify efficiently but
you you can't generate efficiently and
copilot really I mean it's it's
autopilot for programming right and
currently is doing the link following
which is like the simple copy paste and
sometimes suggest uh but over time it's
going to become more and more autonomous
and so the same thing will play out in
not just coding but actually across many
many different things probably but
coding is an important one right like
writing programs yeah what how do you
see the future of that developing uh the
program synthesis like being able to
write programs that are more and more
complicated because right now it's human
supervised in interesting ways yes like
what it feels like the transition will
be very painful
my mental model for it is the same thing
will happen as with the autopilot uh So
currently is doing link following is
doing some simple stuff and eventually
we'll be doing autonomy and people will
have to intervene less and less and
there could be like you like testing
mechanisms
like if it writes a function and that
function looks pretty damn correct but
how do you know it's correct because
you're like getting lazier and lazier as
a programmer like your ability to
because like little bugs but I guess it
won't make a little no it will it
copilot will make uh off by one subtle
bugs it has done that to me but do you
think future systems will or is it
really the off by one is actually a
fundamental challenge of programming in
that case it wasn't fundamental and I
think things can improve but uh yeah I
think humans have to supervise I am
nervous about people not supervising
what comes out and what happens to for
example the proliferation of bugs in all
of our systems I'm nervous about that
but I think there will probably be some
other copilots for bug finding and stuff
like that at some point because there
will be like a lot more automation for
uh oh man
so it's like a program a co-pilot that
generates a compiler for one that does a
linter yes one that does like a a type
Checker yes
it's a committee of like a GPT sort of
like and then they'll be like a manager
for the committee yeah and then there'll
be somebody that says a new version of
this is needed we need to regenerate it
yeah there were 10 gpts that were
forwarded and gave 50 suggestions
another one looked at it and picked a
few that they like a bug one looked at
it and it was like it's probably a bug
they got re-ranked by some other thing
and then a final Ensemble uh GPT comes
in it's like okay given everything you
guys have told me this is probably the
next token you know the feeling is the
number of programmers in the world has
been growing and growing very quickly do
you think it's possible that it'll
actually level out and drop to like a
very low number with this kind of world
because then you'll be doing software
2.0 programming
um and you'll be doing this kind of
generation of copilot type systems
programming but you won't be doing the
old school
software 1.0 program I don't currently
think that they're just going to replace
human programmers
um
it's I'm so hesitant saying stuff like
this right because this is going to be
replaced in five years and no it's going
to show that like this is where we
thought because I I agree with you but I
think we might be very surprised
right like what are the next
I I what's your sense of where we stand
with language models like does it feel
like the beginning or the middle or the
end the beginning 100 I think the big
question in my mind is for sure GPT will
be able to program quite well
confidently and so on how do you steer
the system you still have to provide
some guidance to what you actually are
looking for and so how do you steer it
and how do you say how do you talk to it
how do you um
audit it and verify that what is done is
correct and how do you like work with
this and it's as much not just an AI
problem but a UI ux problem yeah um so
beautiful fertile ground for so much
interesting work uh for vs code plus
plus where you're not just it's not just
human programming anymore it's amazing
yeah so you're interacting with the
system so not just one prompt but it's
iterative prompting yeah you're trying
to figure out having a conversation with
the system yeah that actually I mean to
me that's super exciting to have a
conversation with the program I'm
writing
yeah maybe at some point uh you're just
conversing with it it's like okay here's
what I want to do actually this variable
maybe it's not even that low level as
variable but you can also Imagine like
can you translate this to C plus plus
and back to python yeah that already
kind of exists no but just like doing it
as part of the program experience like I
think I'd like to write this function as
C plus plus
or like you just keep changing for
different uh different programs because
they're different syntax maybe I want to
convert this into a functional language
yeah and so like you get to become
multilingual as a programmer and dance
back and forth efficiently yeah I mean I
think the UI ux of it though is like
still very hard to think through because
it's not just about writing code on a
page you have an entire developer
environment you have a bunch of hardware
on it uh you have some environmental
variables you have some scripts that are
running in a chrome job like there's a
lot going on to like working with
computers and how do these uh systems
set up environment flags and work across
multiple machines and set up screen
sessions and automate different
processes like how all that works and is
auditable by humans and so on is like
massive question at the moment